you'd be hard-pressed to find something
funnier than callan's stand-up
except for callum when he's serious
all right dude let's move on with these
brian callan coming to town this weekend
that's right
you'd be hard-pressed to find a funnier
guy unless he's being serious we'll be
right back for news weather traffic
and you hear that you're like what the
[ __ ] were you guys talking about in the
break
no no no we're just uh so you're here
you're in
ohio i don't know portland helium this
weekend
can't watch him i'll do a couple minutes
will yeah i don't well i'm not really
just fly up and do a couple okay yeah
all right yeah yeah
yeah well i don't that's not really
portland where they're shutting where
they're
picketing white-owned uh white-owned
restaurants because they're they're
they're they're cooking ethnic
food are they really yeah what oh yeah
wait they're what because if you're a
white owned if you're a white
owner of a restaurant but you're serving
a fusion of ethnic food
no culturally appropriate there's gonna
be more to it than that there sure
ain't this this this burrito thing these
two white women who'd gotten to mexico
and
figured out a way to make these amazing
burritos they were
shut down because they were they were
appropriating their mexican culture
that's amazing well i don't know it's
amazing well then i'm shutting down your
performance in the hangover movies
yeah you're not that guy you're not i'm
not lebanese i'm not eighteen
not all performances you were never that
guy that's what i mean yes that's acting
dude that's what i mean
yeah i think i'm liberal though see yeah
yeah but you get so like
um if you're unreal that you don't even
know the real deal
yeah that's not what i was trying to say
i wasn't exactly what thank you
oh don't thank me man i was trying to
say something about the way it is
[ __ ] i win
um tragic news out of marina del rey
he was so [ __ ] real about it that the
doctors came in did an autopsy and said
natural causes he's in perfect health
he [ __ ] keeps it so real he just said
i win and he [ __ ]
passed away 31. chris remember the time
we were talking about
the song to play at brian's funeral do
you remember the name of that song
it was like some like [ __ ] trap
oh yeah yeah the [ __ ] was that song oh
[ __ ]
i think i got it what was it i think i
remember guys number one he was our
biggest influence yeah
down my cheeks to flying from my eyes
who would do that so
you guys could cry you would commission
you guys would cry
to come back and do your funeral songs
you guys were crying
the first time tears shot out of
someone's eyes
the teeth are flying from my eyes not my
tears my cheeks are dry but i'm crying
hard
why why why why why because i'm trying
so hard i'm trying to tear some flying
from my eyes
rotten from my eyes dude the number one
hit if i
please yeah if i live you i want to take
this
piece of podcasting set it to music yeah
wow recipes brian there's another
another single here
you're doing good you're 51 years old
crushing it and like i've said before
on on many mediums well whatever it's
not that's no no no i want to
you want to find it well here's what i
was going to say i have it i have it i i
was going to say about brian
51. yeah could beat the living [ __ ] out
of cm punk
10 years younger thanks you can no this
guy brian you could beat cm punk
he could beat the [ __ ] tar out of him
i think really yeah i want to see that
all right in the ufc one last fight hey
he had
what was his name mike jackson yeah
that's the only reason i remember it
i'll beat i'll be chris's ass i'll tell
you that much why don't you dress up
like sam couldn't chris
all right a lot of people say i look
like cm yeah let's catch your hair
no because in his career i'll be over no
right um
uh you could yeah i i watched that fight
going okay
so they just kind of throw in he's an
entertainer yeah right he's a
professional wrestler he's been training
for a couple years to do
something you know that's other let's
call it other yeah
uh you're primarily you're you're an
actor you're a
comedian you're a you know whatever the
[ __ ]
tennis player boxer wrestling and so uh
i would say tennis player
but i come off the ground when i hit i
mean the top's been so stupid
oh this is my funeral song
yup this was it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
is that it though
yeah god will you kill it on this song
huh
that's my that's my funeral that's your
funeral song and chris and i will come
in
are you guys carrying my my coffin we're
going to be we're just floating next to
your coffin like this
am i not hearing it we're the only
pallbearers no i want to be wrapped like
a mummy and you guys are carrying me
wrapped like a mummy yeah and white and
white we're just making you float
i'm on your i'm on your shoulder i'm on
your shoulder my body's rigged mortis
your wife's crying
[Music]
yeah and then we do that and wink at my
wife with my with me on your shoulder
wrapped in gauze
you know uh you know out here in la in
southern california they have those sign
flippers they have in other parts of the
country where it's like
subway sandwich 5.99 come check out
these new apartments
that's what we do with brian's corpse at
the [ __ ] funeral and we just flip it
around and spin it in the air chicken
suits
yeah and chicken suits to that song
oh that would be a cool funeral brand
what are you surfing for food what do
you serve
bacon two white women are gonna make
burritos there you go
there you go there you go two white
women who went to mexico
are super foodies hey you know what
let's start a restaurant
people [ __ ] loved it yeah and now
just while flipping brian's body with
chicken suits on
while white women make burritos wife
crying so hard
and then i bust out of the gauze and i'm
like psych
and i cut both your throats okay i drink
your blood
um oh man i'm tired today
all right flew around yesterday i'm
tired today uh
uh all right an airplane that kept
delaying it was that a new in new york
they had that nor'easter i guess right i
hate the norwegian
yeah like it's just not done don't say
that
right um i mean this would this podcast
could just be a day
what a day long oh yeah yeah let's keep
going i'll tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected